there was a Filipino chick when I was in
the Navy oh I'll never forget here we go
you know there was there was there was
the Elephant Bar on like Tuesday nights
up in like it wasn't La Jolla but I
don't know where it was but anyways yeah
a lot of military guys went there
because it was like dollar beers or
something right so I remember this this
Filipino chick was just all over me one
night and I was like and I never mess
with a Filipino chick yeah right do you
have an accent or America no she was
straight
she came from the from is Manila
I'm so confident I didn't know about
Atlanta so I was like
no no she was first generation yeah yeah
and also I remember was we go back to
her place and I was like oh it's about
to pop off it's crazy it's so unexpected
and I look and on next to her nightstand
she had a picture of her and this white
dude and he had like scuba gear on I go
who's that she goes oh no husband he he
gone and I was like where's he at
[__] was a Navy SEAL I was like
I'm out oh really and she was like she
goes no no he didn't I said no no then
[__] come home at any second he
probably got some infrared [__] going on
right now I couldn't have got out that
[__] fast enough I remember she
just said that yeah you're fine be
honest you did it no really I dipped wow
I was scared bro you heard this first I
was stationed at the seals right goes
Trump's [__] maybe yeah yeah now if she
was a black girl with a fat ass I'm out
of state
really it was just she was just so
aggressive towards you when I was even
trying you don't [__] white girls not
really no no it's it's let me just say
something to you my friend what is it
about why the white woman that you don't
like
I always say like this
it's not I don't like white women it's
just like a light I like black women and
it's like gay if you're gay you know
you're gay you don't know why you're gay
you're just gay I like black women I
don't know it's just what I like I can
relate to this you don't over we
overthink [__] with relationships we try
to go all deep and it's like my dick
gets hard and I go this is what we're
doing
let's go great let's ride let's ride
that's great yeah I can relate to that I
think that
um even though I have dated white guys
my I usually
the [__] does not react to white guys
so it's usually just
that's a little deep and I go thank you
but I get so much [__] about this when I
say it out loud what do you prefer just
brown guys always Asian Latino black
anything but white even though I've
dated white guys in like the past but I
haven't in the last I think 15 years all
right let's see don't overthink it you
don't overthink it at all what do you
like Bobby
[Music]
that's interesting that you say that
yeah I do say it yeah I I know you said
I [__] heard you say it yeah I want
to know and you're gonna know okay let
me ask you a question the [__] I
will ask the answer the question
[__] do it all right
do you think I'm gay
why'd you get up like that I think
you've touched a dick
and we'll be we'll be back after this
uh I will say I think you you did quote
unquote Hollywood
I think you came to town and you were
like I'm doing the drugs I'm
experimenting sexually I'm doing it
[__] all bro whoa that's heavy dude
that's like what Tom Hardy says he's
like he's someone asked him like have
you ever had like experiences he was
like I've lived in Hollywood long enough
what do you think Hmm Venom this I'm not
gonna say I'm not gonna say I'm not
gonna respond to that all I'm gonna say
is I'm sober now
I'm sober now a couple years almost you
know I feel great yeah almost I'm 52
years old I know what I want you know
what I mean and I'm going to say this
dude you know let bygones be bygones I'm
not judging you I feel like you are dog
I'm not at all dude I don't I don't
attack I wouldn't come on here if I was
judges yeah and so it's like Bobby I'm
not judging you you can come here and
flex all you want dog you know I mean
you asked him I know I don't know I
don't know
don't be answering my question honestly
yeah yeah and could I also by the way
just factually right I knew that there
was only Atlanta was Georgia and that
was the only Atlanta okay yeah I'm not
that dumb okay all right my point is my
point being is yeah I don't even want to
talk to your point I mean there are a
couple Georges in the world yes so maybe
you thought you know what I mean like
Panama City